Marta Schuster's roses in her own garden
are her pride and joy nine years ago she
and her family moved from Poland to
Germany they bought their house for
little money and spent years renovating
and expanding it affects nah it was all
tangley the grass was knee-high and we
had trouble getting through because
everything was covered in weeds Alice
someone called Quebec Sandra moving to
Germany was a huge opportunity for Marta
here she runs her own care service and
several vacation homes in addition she
could take care of her children and work
from home the family could only find a
big enough house in Germany word of
spreading the properties are cheaper in
this part of Germany than in neighboring
Poland both laughing phonebook I often
received messages from acquaintances or
even people I don't know asking if I
have any hot tips for a house or a nice
piece of property available for sale
real estate is becoming scarce up one in
eight residents of Garth's a small town
and the river oder is from Poland and
the numbers are rising
and the Germans are they getting used to
the Polish neighbors bringing new life
to the place as long as they don't harm
us and we don't harm them and they make
sure to integrate themselves into
society and work hard and they stay
approachable and do their work I've got
no problem the harmonious coexistence
was whoever put to the test when the
local elementary school introduced
polish lessons for German children some
protested but the local council and
school management's were soon able to
win over the critics we have 205
children that go to school here 80 of
them are Polish so it's clear that they
too are vital for this school by now
nine German pupils take part and mr.
Tanaka's cheerful polish course many
kids in our class are from Poland and
when they speak Polish we want to be
able to understand them and when we go
to Poland we want to be able to say
something
the Germans often cross into Poland the
Polish town of graffito is much closer
than any big German town here shopping
might be inexpensive but the real estate
prices are quite high that's why many
Poles choose to live in Germany and many
more say they would be happy to follow I
don't say no maybe some someday we will
go there and live there Marta Schuster
has never regretted her decision to move
to an area that many Germans consider
the end of the world and not at all this
year is the beginning of the world
because it's so beautiful here we're
surrounded by nature and nice people
what more could we want once a year
their idyllic retreat is noisily
disrupted when the festival and the
German bank of the oder liven things up
with its rustic humour rough-and-tumble
fun
and German March music it doesn't get
more traditional than this but Martha
Shuster and her polish friends have no
problem you're in Germany so it's fine
that it's typically German
European freedom of movement here in the
small town of guards it's become a part
of everyday life
[Music]